[Music]
if you think making the Marvel's theme
song out of an old timey rag time tune
is enough to make me enjoy sitting
through it you're wrong but pretty close
though nice try in case you confused it
with Chicago Kansas the ghost town not
the bands just to clarify we never want
to S to be vague our nitpicking is
always specific ific and never confusing
and it shall remain so get back someone
will see you you don't exactly blend in
neither do you you're wearing trousers
Heen when he's back where he belongs a
top of the
TVA you and I will be right by his side
well sides you can't both be right by
his side because that implies you'd be
standing on the same side and one of you
would be physically closer than the
other so one will stand on the left and
the other on the right right right how
much time do we have OB will now pause
for a second as he remembers they need
to keep the countdown vague enough to
stretch the pacing to fit six episodes
so you'll never know to the minute how
much time is left just that they're in a
Perpetual state of about to die no one's
going to die mispronouncing everyone why
would you go to the same place twice I
don't know because it's like 3:00 a.m.
and you live in a small town you're a
little drunk and Waffle House is the
only thing open for like 100 miles is
that a good enough reason for you Loki
not adding in Miss M's legs she has legs
where's your sense of journalistic
integrity the daily Chicago press you
draw the subject of your front page
story legless
disrespectful you're a man of action
which is fine I take a more slow
deliberate cerebral approach feels like
this line was written by a staff member
right after the Marvel execs called this
season slow and cerebral and turning
Mobius into a self insert is something
that should be reserved for fanfiction
specifically my FanFiction where he and
Loki are dating I call it lokus but only
because Moby Dick was already taken
somehow he could produce an entire
culture down to a simple diarama winking
at what you're doing doesn't make it
better Disney why they include Boulder's
even heard of him I have and I've imp
patiently waiting for him to show up in
the
MCU honestly not really worth the wait I
understand we need this visual clue so
they can find Kang or whatever but every
other name on the list is a German
musical performance why is Victor
presenting here nothing about him or his
invention is German it has no ties to
Germany and there aren't even any other
inventors on this sign make it make
sense Marvel would you kindly open the
bag unless you want everyone freaking
out you stay in that bag until I tell
you otherwise okay how does Miss minutes
work how's she even contained by a bag
she's an advanced sentient AI capable of
running the entire TVA but now she's
stuck in a bag is she attached to a
micro projector don't see you even
though I'm not sure why they need to
hide can't the man who makes all the
Illusions disguise himself in mobus so
Rin Slayer wouldn't recognize them we
already saw in Thor to when he turned
Thor into cth that Loki can project his
Illusions onto other people why does the
Magic Man continue to not magic and just
what would you know about the Future Boy
racist hecklers who interrupt stage
performers actually just go ahead and
throw us in in there for the non-racist
hecklers too with my device the wattage
Edison uses to light a single bulb can
light the whole of Chicago using your
device to back Edison instead of t
didn't you watch The Prestige Victor
Edison was a jerk you don't want to help
him laugh it off as pure science fiction
I would but the term science fiction
wasn't actually used until the 1920s and
since you haven't technically been to
that decade yet you shouldn't even know
the phrase welcome to the Future my
friend he says as the entire machine
starts sparking and goes out but
everyone keeps applauding I guess I
should give them a break they're
probably bored a sh what are they even
doing with their lives besides denter
also why does mobus look impressed he
nearly got skinned alive by the real
version of this machine it's like me
going back in time and being impressed
with a typewriter you can't trust a
variant of he who remains in the TVA
yeah that'd be like trusting the variant
of Loki in the TVA huh what happened in
season one again it's hard to tell what
Bill timely slipping is accomplice here
but I take issue with its singular
nature he just helped timely make a
grand he's getting ripped off how about
we settled this outside man he stepped
on your shoe since 1800s it's probably
caked in hor anyway let it
go hang on Loki's Powers up into this
point have mostly been Illusions now
sure season one added dagger summoning
and energy blast but now he can straight
up teleport people away you can't just
color whatever he does green and expect
us to go oh that must be something Loki
can do now you need to set up some clear
rules or limits to his powers and it
shouldn't include stepping on the toes
of Kurt Vagner panical trousers I know
movus I'm shocked too no one steals from
wallet and grommit and gets away with it
we have a he who remains variant wait if
they're on the sacred timeline can there
be any variants present wouldn't this
mean timely is the original version and
he who remains is the variant oh wait my
bad I actually don't give a but if the
loom fails and a TVA is destroyed there
won't be a life to go back to is this
confirmed I thought he remains put
together the TVA to stop his variance
from popping up not to save all of time
itself though maybe that's one in the
same or maybe I still don't give a sh I
play that you tried to kill me card
Mobius you and I both know that depends
entirely on how much Mana you have free
on the field check and see what you have
tapped I'm not teaching you how to play
this game again if you in the TVA hadn't
messed with him he'd have remained
harmless not necessarily K could have
had a thousand other plans to reactivate
him or maybe he' have found a way to
time travel and figure things out on his
own there's just no way to know he'd be
harmless for
sure
run I ask again how does Miss minutes
work are her foots steps causing the
sound or is she broadcasting what they
should sound like and is she a
projection or does she have some kind of
hard light physical form because she's
tearing down this Banner now just what
are the rules with her and it I actually
do give a sh this can go down to
40° wow 40° you say that's practically
summer temps when you're in the middle
of a windy city winter Chicago Winters
it took 2 minutes to almost lose the
upper half of my ears to frostbite just
getting off the L
a refrigerator chair yeah refrigerator
chair I want one of these now why is he
selling go- go gadget pants instead of
these things refrigerators haven't even
been invented yet I'm here because I
know what a great man you can become I'm
starting to get a little uncomfortable I
mean I'm sure they won't but if the
writers do go down the path of a Mis
minutes romance I feel obligated to warn
you that's worth an automatic 24 CS one
for each hour of the day we had to stop
encouraging Appliance romances after
Jeremy started getting a little too into
his Brave Little Toaster fan fck he
switches sides it's a Well documented
behavioral trait show thinks will'll
take a sin off for this obvious nod to
Loki's history in the MCU and show
underestimates how tired we are of
self-referential humor now we eat an
apple or something already geez I do all
my cells in Chicago um but my lab is in
Wisconsin but earlier you said your lab
was across the lake and I hate to be the
bear of bad news but if you're Crossing
Lake Michigan from Chicago you're
arriving in Michigan in fact I can show
you exactly where on my left hand his
face looks a lot worse now than it did
in the cabin
earlier remember when Loki did cool
stuff besides just generically blasting
people with green particle effects
remember in season 1 when richardy Grant
made that super cool City illusion to
distract the giant smoke monster I
missed that this is the Loki equivalent
of an old man Neo from Matrix
resurrections just kind of blows people
back with his powers or whatever this
way away from their hiding spot even
though they have no reason to move from
this spot while they wait for the trace
maybe they're leaving for more snacks
excuse me oh excuse me continually
cutting in line I wonder if it's because
he's obsessed with controlling time and
even doing little things like cutting in
line makes him feel like he's in control
of the way time flows around him or
maybe he's just a prick and now the
shore appears to be going by them on the
starboard side which means they're going
south towards Indiana instead of north
towards Wisconsin like he said you're
going to end up in Gary Indiana the
place that proves you should never name
a city the same thing you'd name a male
child born in 1947 you brought it to him
the way the postman brings the post no
she didn't the book she delivered wasn't
bent in half and crammed under my door
half chewed by a dog I always knew my
ideas were good I just didn't have the
technology to make
them really work I also don't think you
had the basic fundamentals of advanced
mathematics and physics to be able to
understand anything in that book but
what do I know definitely not advanced
mathematics or physics is is the answer
betrayed by your allies dropped into the
middle of a lake while you're sleeping
and not a single curse word I'm not
buying it and she instantly starts
rowing she's so determined I mean look
at how hard she's rowing I don't want
anything in life bad enough to row that
hard hell I don't even want to not be
stranded in the middle of a lake bad
enough to row that hard I'm sitting this
because it makes me question my own lack
of ambition I have a um a seat float
offering your s and Ai and ice cream
float when you know she can't taste or
touch the magic that is ice cream or can
she you're so much like him well yeah
kind of is him or will be aren they I
supposed to be smart is there a sketch
of made in that journal yours this
entire paint me like one of your French
hlos [__] why didn't you allow me a
real body clock blocking your clock teas
put that down don't do this for you need
me I love you so timely shuts her down
but how she has a remote and an off
switch then how do she operate
independently when raona got to Chicago
in the beginning of the episode Miss
minutes was waiting for her right where
was her remote then the fact that I'm
spending multiple sins trying to figure
out exactly what turns on a clock in
both senses of the word was not on my
Marvel bingo card today who enters a
secret lab like that you're not going to
scope out the place first make use of a
little stealth you're just going to go
full Kramer you never go full Kramer
move any closer and he's done I mean not
really if you prune him it'll just be
spit out at the end of time and we've
already seen that area can be easily
accessed with a temp pad so kind of an
empty threat rinse layer we've all lost
our way but someone has to keep track of
the big picture here plea from the
screenwriters to Kevin feige somehow
makes its way into the episode I suppose
I've been a box you've been wanting to
take for a long time I mean she did tick
your box in season 1 right why can't I
remember season 1 at all
hold on how the did ren Slayer get this
back from Victor he was the one who
imprisoned Miss minutes did Paul Rudd
teacher slight of hand also you stranded
her at the end of time but you didn't
check her for a temp pad how dumbb are
you Sylvie she can just pop back
anywhere with that little device this is
like my mom grounding me for my N64 but
forgetting I have a Game Boy in my
backpack to be set a drift on Lake
Michigan a human popsicle what welcome
to the world of
Tomorrow a book about me I'll be a
star I regret nothing except this part
but there was one whim you never allowed
me why didn't you allow me a real body I
knew it you're trying to seduce me